un jefe de estado asesinado el 7 de
julio de 2021 el presidente haitiano yo
en el mois murió en su casa a manos de
hombres armados
es político
todos sin importar las inclinaciones
políticas sin importar las ideologías
políticas todos en el país estamos en
shock
porque simplemente no estábamos
esperando que esto sucediera nadie había
anticipado este acto bárbaro
nada
las investigaciones revelan que el
asesinato de moix fue planeado desde
república dominicana por un grupo de
mercenarios entre ellos 26 colombianos
algunos ex militares y dos
estadounidenses de origen haitiano de
modo las instrucciones
nacional a nuestra policía y al ejército
para que te envía siempre este la
colaboración en el estado de
investigación para que se esclarezca
esto 6 a pesar de una multitud de
arrestos hasta ahora no se sabe quién es
el autor intelectual del atentado al
mandatario hasta 2015 ellos en el movice
no era conocido en el ámbito político de
haití su éxito como empresario le dio
esperanzas a los haitianos en un país
sumido en una larga profunda crisis
sociopolítica y económica el 7 de
febrero de 2017 moix asumió la
presidencia bajo las sospechas de fraude
el peso de las protestas callejeras y la
desconfianza de sus detractores tras su
muerte el primer ministro designado
ariel on y anunció que planea celebrar
las elecciones presidenciales a más
tardar en el segundo semestre de 2022